China is carving out a new image on the
world stage after claiming to have won
the battle against coronavirus the
Chinese government is sending
much-needed supplies to pandemic
stricken countries including the United
States Raby Inocencio joins us now from
Tokyo with more good morning here in
Japan coronavirus infections have now
topped the 3000 mark and Tokyo's
governor thinks the central government
is now ready to declare a national
emergency
meantime in China a very different story
reported infections have plunged
dramatically in the country is now
extending help around the world a plane
bearing the logo of the New England
Patriots landed in Boston Friday it had
been dispatched to China where it picked
up a shipment of 1.2 million n95 masks
governor Charlie Baker struck a deal
with Chinese manufacturers
these made-in-china scenes had been
playing out around the world and they're
not just shipping masks but personal
protective equipment ventilators and
even medical personnel China sent over
30 tons of equipment to Italy delivered
500,000 surgical masks to Spain and
donated 5 million more to neighbor South
Korea there's also the question of
China's credibility the country has
officially reported more than 80,000
infections and 3,300 deaths of figure
president Trump publicly disputed yeah
their numbers seemed to be a little bit
on the light side and I'm being nice
when I say that relative to what we
witnessed and what was reported that's
an allegation dismissed by Chinese
officials as an unfortunate mistake we
sympathize with the u.s. as they face a
severe situation said watch one gain
from the Ministry of Foreign Affairs and
I can imagine why some in the country
are trying so hard to shift the blame
now China's foreign ministry has also
claimed it's been open transparent and
responsible with its numbers it's also
important to note that many other
countries have numbers that are
unreliable at least to some degree that
includes for reasons like underestimates
censorship and the lack of testing and
includes countries like Russia the
United Kingdom and the United States
cracy BS this morning Saturday Ramey
innocencio Tokyo what is it that we keep
saying we are all in this together